ça vous passez pas de problème de mettre
en application un décret alors même
qu'on n'a pas encore voté la nouvelle
loi un décret a été pris écrit hier
publié aujourd'hui au journal officiel
pour application dès demain ce qui
normalement ne permet pas d'ailleurs au
président de l'assemblée nationale de
l'appliquer ce soir parce qu'on n'est
pas encore demain il ya des questions de
droit à un moment donné mais ceci je le
mets de côté
mais à quoi on sert ici à part faire
figurants protesté un peu quand même
histoire de dire qu'à une démocratie une
des discussions
enfin c'est insupportable ça ne vous
choque pas que des décret soit pris
comme ça sans aucune discussion
préalable
[Musique]